[Music]
I'm the one
oh my God so okay you you missed it you
were like you know 50 seconds off of Tom
giving some inappropriate jokes
hilarious but we're not gonna repeat it
no we're not going to just gonna get
into it every time you want to no no no
no no no
what did I say I said about what the the
economy no no he had he had a nice joke
he said that uh inappropriate for uh
podcast but it's fun if it's uh not on
but it's great to be here today it's
great to be here today we got uh Adam
Vinnie uh Biz Doc in the house uh we we
made by the way we may uh introduce the
link to the tickets to the first live we
were at the event yes do I have to buy
tickets you got to buy two tickets but
yesterday we were at the voice in my
head for the voice of my head yes how
did you know we had a lot of things to
talk about so if you if you can see this
here McCarthy goes to the White House
and they increase the rates by only a
quarter I know that you're you like that
I love them
increasing in money if there's everybody
is wondering what Vinnie's take is on
federal proof's quarter point rate
coming uh we want to hear about it we
got a bunch of different stories we got
to get into how many how many live
viewers do we need to get to in order to
make this announcement today let's give
the our friends a challenge I think
that's I think that we can make the
announcement at six thousand we get to
okay guys don't let us down no no so
here's what we got here we got Ron
DeSantis Rhonda Santos for the first
time they say took a shot at Trump right
now we'll we'll see if that qualifies as
a shot or not Nikki Haley is apparently
announcing a run for president and she
apparently called Donald Trump we'll
talk about that Chad gbt there's a few
different things going on there the
teachers Rejoice Chad gbt creators have
released a tool to help detect AI
generated writing for teachers and
they're fired up about it Elon Musk
pushes uh forward with Twitter payments
Vision he's got a few things going on
fed approves the rate hacks we'll talk
about that the biggest risk to Market is
no recession at all in 2023. J.P Morgan
strategists say that's a uh Insider
story uh some say we may be facing the
depression like of a recession that's
going to be coming not a good look and
by the way that article I don't know who
it's from it's uh depression Fox
Business we'll talk about that home
prices fell in November for fifth or
eighth month uh how much tips should you
leave this is a story that Adam's very
committed to as a guy who doesn't like
to leave tips
on tips fake news fake news Twitter
Twitter lashes out at billmar following
new CNN segment announcement Tom Brady
announces retirement Hunter writing
threatened to withhold assistants pay
for sex who would believe a story like
this who would believe a story like that
but we're gonna dive into it with Alec
Baldwin
Adam's got some feedback on Tyree
Nichols first person uh
has the first person been born to live
250 years old which is kind of
interesting maybe that person's in this
room we don't know maybe and the last
but not least the collapse of faith in
America we know you got strong opinions
about that so having said that I say we
get right into economy Tom and talk
about the rate hikes if you guys are
okay with that let me see here okay
Federal proof's quarter point rate hike
signals more increases likely
this is a Wall Street Journal story page
eight if you want to go to it you know
it would be interesting if we can get
the audience to follow with us if we
actually gave PDFs I was in Civil War
members awesome if we can do something
where members can get PDFs and I can
just print it out and follow the story
with us by the way if you're interested
in that give us a thumbs up and
subscribe maybe we'll do it on the next
episode I got it pbds PDFs it's it's a
it's like it's a duet like no other Tom
and I couldn't even imagine what you
just said right okay that's what we're
doing Federal proofs quarter rate hikes
uh signals more increases likely the
Federal Reserve approved an interest
rate increase of a quarter of a
percentage point and Signal plans to
raise again next month to continue
lowering inflation the decision
Wednesday following sixth consecutive uh
rate Rises that were larger including an
increase of a half a point in December
and uh three quarters of a point in
November the committee anticipates that
ongoing increases in interest rates will
be appropriate in order to attain
extensive monetary policy that is
sufficient sufficiently restrictive the
latest increased caps a year in which
the FED lifted its Benchmark federal
funds rate from a near zero to a range
of four and a half to four and three
quarters a level last reached in 2007 we
can now say for the first time that this
inflationary process has started the
federal chair Jerome Powell said the job
is not fully done Tom what are your
thoughts on this
well remember
um Jay Powell has said
that until inflation is at what percent
or I can see it or I can see it from
here
um see the whites of their eyes I'm
going to keep raising rates so he said
the disinflationary process has started
what he means by that is he's starting
to see the peak and flatten and like can
momentum start to come down but he says
he's still going to be raising rates
what this means to people listening is
that all those headlines you see about
tech layoffs it's not just going to be
Tech there's going to be more layoffs in
other sectors because this is going to
slow the economy slow down consumer
spending we've already talked and passed
podcasts about Christmas spending and
things that were down and so this is
just a sign that the worst is over but
he's still going to be putting these
quarter point rates there mortgages
right now are still seven if you don't
have perfect credit seven and a half
even eight if you have horrible credit
and if you have horrible credit and why
are you buying a house right now because
it is going to be for you everybody else
it's uh six and three quarters seven so
this is going to keep slowing down the
economy but he says the job is not fully
done more is coming okay so so you say
that but then I read a story here Tom
from Insider that says the biggest risk
to the market is no recession at all in
JPMorgan strategists say this is an
Insider story as well and this is on
page eight uh it says the biggest threat
to markets right now is as if recession
recession doesn't materialize forcing
the Federal Reserve to remain hawkish
JPMorgan strategist Mike Bell said the S
P 500 NASDAQ Composite are nearly up six
and eleven percent of the past month
respectively as Wall Street sees the FED
reversing its Titan campaign in response
to an economic downturn but if the U.S
economy avoids a recession and wage
growth remains High then the FED would
not cut rates as expected and instead
would have to resume rate hikes in their
second half of the Year lifting them
higher than Wall Street currently
anticipates Bell said unfortunately at
that point you're back into a world
where both bonds and stocks would go
down together he said but jpmorgan's
best case assumes there will be a
recession in 20 2023 that will allow
wage pressures to moderate and feds to
cut rate in 2024. does that make sense
to you it does make sense and what it
means is this can I just paint a
different picture okay
the economy is the cheerleader okay okay
what does she look like uh she's
upstairs in her bedroom and Jerome
Powell's in there with the cheerleader
okay and until the economy this is an
analogy foreign
exactly and until the economy starts
cooling down which would be your parents
headlights coming into the driveway he's
not leaving the bedroom and running out
the back door wow that is what's
happening so the economy is going to
keep getting pounded by these interest
rates
Tom please continue to tell me how
Jerome Powell's up in the bedroom
pounding the economy I gotta know
running out the back door that's exactly
but that's the way to look at this
that's what JPMorgan is saying is unless
we have a recession which is a little
bit of pain and shift in the economy
Powell's not gonna move the interest
rate so in other words until we have the
pain of recession and some unemployment
which is terrible part of the pain but
it's part of it and we have you know
price starts to come down price coming
down on eggs would be a nice thing
especially for the Egg Master thank you
but until that happens and so I'll use a
more I'll use a nicer a nicer approach
you know if you you're out there
snowboarding and you tear up your knee
stretching that knee after the surgery
if anybody's ever had a knee injury is
horrible you go to the doctor and it's
horribly painful stretching the knee is
what has to happen for our economy and
there is going to be some unemployment
there is going to be prices come down
and it's going to be tough and if that
doesn't happen JP Morgan saying if we
don't get a little bit of pain and that
doesn't happen then he's going to keep
raising rates and which they went into a
technical terminology which means bonds
and stocks both end up in a bad place
and the economy doesn't have a chance to
kind of cool off okay little Pat so I
mean Tom so he's up there a lot of pain
a lot of pounding is there any way he
could stimulate like the economy with
some I don't know like Viagra I mean
some stimulus here's a challenge to to
continue with the analogy that you're
taking yeah and the pounding that Tom
took to go with that analogy here's what
you have to be thinking about yeah
imagine honestly imagine straight up if
you're on Viagra yes four ten and a half
you're straight every single day you're
just taken Viagra yeah that's what
happened to the economy 128 economic
expansion see how we did that so that
that's the that's the challenge of
what's going on today we've been on
Cialis Cialis and freaking all these
guys Non-Stop and now the economy is
like dude I gotta take a break I gotta
take a break by the way shout out to our
responses
we have to go see a doctor let me tell
you
wife's wishes I've had two yetis full of
coffee today and that's probably the
issue
so my my warning to you all no think
about also think about it this way
Vinnie once the economy shifts and the
prices of things come down even though
there's some unemployment what are the
people that have jobs start doing they
start buying incremental things again
maybe traveling a little bit more and so
what that means is GDP goes back up
because people start spending naturally
and prices have come down a little bit
that's the whole circle of life they're
trying to manipulate here but is there
going to be like a moment you guys think
and Tom do you guys think you tried them
is it gonna be like a moment where it's
like all right guys the [__] at the fan
we're like is there an announcement when
you hit like a real deal recession like
that's really bad it tends to be a slow
drip drip drip I'm gonna drip like in
2008 when I when I experienced my first
like yeah Taste Of The Nightlife yeah
was it was markets down 500 today
Market's down 800 today we're talking
about the Dow typically yeah Market's
down 900 boom we're down a thousand and
then it's like next thing you know we're
down 40 or whatever the number was slow
drip drip drip trip you you were already
just starting
you think I think you had just started
PHP right after that I want to say so
that was so there's no actual moment
just everybody looks around and goes
it's we're inside of it right now can I
can I give a little yeah so number one
shout out to who I think is the most
important figure in America today uh
it's his birthday this weekend
and uh I'm not talking about me we share
the same birthday I'm talking about
Jerome Powell February 4th pull them up
Rob just so I can fact check this thing
let's take a look at this let's see the
cheerleader I already sent it to Rob but
now he's doing the work the cheerleader
boom look at that February 4th shout out
to him but
53 so this is a zero birthday for him
man it is it was gonna be 70. shout out
to my to my dad
but I just want to give you some some
quick numbers real quick just so you can
kind of wrap your head around the
numbers because I think Pat teed up
exactly what we should be discussing is
that
these prognosticators who are there's a
recession in 2023 no way it's going to
be 2024. what's Biden going to do no way
Biden's going to enter a 2024 election
if there's a recession he's going to
stimulate the economy whatever it is
here's just some numbers for you
inflation for the year I know is up as
high as eight percent overall was 6.5
year over year last year I think they
want to keep it somewhere around two to
three percent so it's almost double
where we'd like it to be in the United
States unemployment somehow is still
three and a half percent I know that you
think that's gonna increase dramatically
over the next few years we'll see the
last time it was three and a half
percent was under the Trump
Administration I want to say somewhere
in the 2018 range where he was bragging
about hey this is you know lowest
unemployment lowest uh blacks Asians
whites it was It was obviously a great
time for the economy at that point but
here's where I want to go to this we've
talked about this a few times this fear
greed index uh CNN does a good job about
this Rob I don't know if you want to
just pull that up the feared greed index
one month so it's zero to a hundred
hundred is like full on Greed zero is
like shockingly fearful
um
right now one month ago one year ago we
were at 28 28 just to put in perspective
that's when crypto started falling yeah
absolute fear extreme fear mode a month
ago it was 38 which was essentially fear
mode essentially way less than neutral
now today we're at 68 which is like
trending towards extreme gear agreed so
I don't know what's happening in the
economy over the last month but some of
these numbers inflation going down
employment ain't strong I don't know I
can't make sense of it is like is the
economy in shambles are we doing better
than ever are people greedy are people
fearful I think to answer your question
I think there's a famous saying like
trying to predict the stock market is
the equivalent of trying to figure out a
drunk stumbling man figuring out his way
home he's just gonna yeah that whole
deal so you know you always hear these
prognosticators
um who continually get it wrong what do
they say like a monkey throwing darts
has a better chance of predicting where
the economy goes last point I wish what
they did like you ever watch uh you know
Fox NFL dollar you know CBS NFL they
show or ESPN they show the whether it's
Stephen A Smith or booger Smith or
whatever these guys names are Chris
Berman all these guys they show their
record for their year against
predictions all right Chris Berman was
uh 48 and 72 this year it's like turns
out he don't know [__] yeah okay I wish
they did that for people in keeping them
financially great for stats great idea
let's forget let's see what happens well
if you take a look here and by the way
thanks for bringing this up Adam this is
really any time Tom no no no
I love what happens no I meant them
Sincerely Adam is talking about a good
index to take a look at and it talks
about the emotion driving the market
it's not necessarily consumers out there
you and me it is the motion driving
Market what has been happening right now
we've had a lot of layoffs the market
likes layoffs because it means a company
is going to be cutting its costs and in
the short time the stock is going to pop
a little bit so guess what greed hey I
can go get a little bit of a pop off
that stock because Facebook you know
laid off people had a pretty reasonable
quarter and they're buying back shares
hey I got a little pop I can get out of
this that is a greed Index this doesn't
necessarily relate to Consumers but
right now with all the layoffs and
things have happened the market is in a
a little pop cycle where people are
investing in it these are sophisticated
Traders and taking advantage of the Pops
that have come from the the layoffs and
the few companies that had reasonable
quarters well let me read this one then
because this kind it goes into uh uh
past the story of greed GDP reveals
uh ominous Great Depression warning sign
not seen since 1932 okay a GDP report
saying that a Great Depression warning
sign not seen since 1932 here's what it
is even the areas that what which
contributed to uh positively to gdpr not
necessarily signs of prosperity for
example business investment grew at only
1.4 percent in the fourth quarter but
that was almost entirely inventory
growth non-residential investment a key
driver of future economic growth was
only up 0.7 percent meanwhile
residential investment fell off a cliff
dropping
26.7 percent as consumers were unable to
afford the combination of high uh home
prices High interest rates and falling
real incomes but perhaps the most
troubling is the precipitous drop in
real disposable income which fell over
one trillion dollars in 2022 for context
this is the second largest percentage
drop in real disposable income ever
behind only 1932 the worst year of the
Great Depression to keep up with
inflation consumers are now depleting
their savings and burning through the
stimulus checks they received during
2020 and 2021. that is the one thing
that I don't think enough people are
talking about you can look at everything
that's good and you can say well look at
what's going on here look at what's
going on there but when people run out
of savings something happens to them and
gradually our savings has gone from 2.1
trillion dollars down a trillion in
savings to 1.1 1.2 trillion dollars
that's like you're having twenty
thousand dollars now you got ten
thousand dollars it's not crazy yet but
you're thinking about it okay
and for for those who were kind of
sitting there being greedy and say well
you know let me tell you what I'm gonna
say I'm not going to sell this for this
price
sales are coming in the next two
quarters sales are coming in an extra
quarters and the credit card balances I
mean you tweeted it out
940 billion yeah 940 billion we were
talking about you and I sat down before
to claim the buck uh show that we had
clay Travis those guys do a great job
but you know the the and by the way do
you remember I don't know if you
remember this maybe you will when we
were doing podcasts and you said Pat I'm
all about save that money look what's
happened ever since we give the stimulus
checks people are paying off the credit
card debt Americans are saving 27
record-breaking I don't know if you
remember this was a month this is so so
Biden's inauguration has won January
2021 March day announced the 1.9
trillion dollars in April the savings
rate in America hits 27 when is the last
time we saved 27 percent 27 you know
what the savings rate is right now 2.4
percent holy [__] by the way lowest it's
been in 17 years lowest it's been in 17
years you know what 17 is 17 is not even
2008 crash 17 is prior to that so these
are things that will be felt you know
somebody the other day on who posted
this on oh uh can you go to Professor
Scott Galloway go to Professor Scott
Galloway's Twitter account he posted
this yesterday and if you guys know who
he is yeah he's a beast he's a uh he's a
beast but he also uh uh is no go to his
okay it's going to be one of his recent
tweets where he talks about the economy
is not as bad as people are saying uh
man I hope you can go to it
if you can't go to it I'm going to read
in my there it is right there click on
that one that's the one zoom in a little
bit real GDP is up 6.7 percent under
Biden we gain four and a half million
jobs in 2022 inflation over the last six
months uh uh is down two percent at an
annual rate economy is doing better than
most Americans think okay now go to the
comments go to the comments go to the
comments go to the comments zoom in a
little bit Todd mitchen tell that to
almost a four dollar gas nine dollar
eggs eight Dollar milk out gas and
electric bill that went up two-thirds
and the countless increases a massive
amounts while literally tens of
thousands of people are being laid off
at a record Pace I like you but your
comments are wrong okay keep going lower
keep going lower so what what he's
saying is he's not feeling it the other
person is saying the average day-to-day
person that's shopping they're feeling
it here's one thing that happens uh uh
when you make money uh the moment you
make money
certain things change meaning a three
dollar increase isn't felt you know a
you know gas prices goes up two dollars
you won't feel it you're like ah gasp I
was filling up my tank at 80 bucks and
that's 110 bucks okay who cares just 30
bucks you know hey you know this thing
that we were paying this much money for
shopping's gone up every month 200 it's
not a big deal it's 200.
two person making money is not a big
deal of course to person that's making
fifty five thousand dollars a year or is
making eighty two thousand dollars
trying to take care of their husband
wife and three kids yeah they're gonna
feel it so uh uh the real pain is felt
by the people and they're savings us
down their confidence is down
um you feel it when you talk to them
they're out of touchpad like all the
late night hacks all the member when the
Putin price all that poo and they're
like I'll happily pay you know five
dollars more or whatever a gallon just
to spin pull his face like okay rich guy
in the bubble what about us what about
the the little guy that's not you know I
mean I can do like gas in LA right now I
saw I think that seven something like
how are you guys living in California
right now with the gas that much and you
have to drive an hour and a half every
single day to work but by the way you
know how they say uh Republicans uh you
know all they care about is they they
want to take care of their uh oil people
is what they want to do this is all they
want to do really okay do you know go to
this article Wall Street Journal I'm
gonna send it to right now uh uh uh do
you know that the oil companies uh a
biggest profitable quarter ever was
under what president was it under Bush
was it under Reagan percentage-wise was
it under Trump I mean it's got to be
under Trump right it has to be under
Trump right nope record-breaking I just
send it to you right now if you see it
record-breaking profits for Exxon Mobil
was under who if you had to guess the
one and only the goat
Joseph Biden oh seriously no question
about it how's that look at the amount
of profits these guys are making under a
Democratic president okay Exxon go to
the top Exxon Exon Exon Exon Vault to
record annual profits of 55.7 billion
dollars under who Joe Biden Joe Biden's
policies well I mean obviously these
guys are more noble people and they
would never help the oil companies make
more money never but they did as weird
as it sounds this is when sometimes you
look at policies and you're like well
those guys are for those guys oh we
would never defend those guys oh we're
given money to help the poor and this is
what we're doing really your policies is
what made America have nearly 10 people
that are worth 100 billion dollars
because when you gave your trillions of
dollars to the poor people or Middle
America all they did is went and gave
the money to the corporations and they
spent the money so
emotionally somebody may say well this
is great I mean we're doing the right
thing such a noble thing you yeah the
problem is people still don't know how
to save the problem is people still
don't know how money works the problem
is people still don't know the basic
fundamentals of things that you do to
manage your finances they still don't
know that you give them more money
they're going to spend it yeah and it's
crazy to see that Pat and especially
with this with the administration's push
on green and no fracking and no nothing
how is that that's crazy to see that
they're making that's a record vaulted
not they didn't say JUMP voted to 55
that's insane yeah I mean they should
Biden and the Democrats should go to the
oil companies and say listen guys
support us next year we're going to make
you more money look how much we've done
for you so go green go Greener yeah
we're gonna get richer they announced it
you know how U-Haul announced the MVP of
the year was Newsom yeah you know did
you hear at their annual convention
annual convention mvpd or Joseph Biden
no I'm just kidding but I mean it should
be hilarious no unit if you listen to
the administration you know you see a
lot of these stats that come out that
that no one in the media words or words
until real numbers show up and then
prove them false and all of the stuff
like on the number of jobs there you saw
one of the responses to it Biden's
saying we've created all these jobs no
he didn't create all these jobs it was
basically if you like to look at
restaurants and hospitality and by the
way part of the American Savings rate
Pat we all know this is Americans
couldn't travel in 2001 couldn't go out
to a dinner couldn't go even for you
know date night out of town to A Little
Spa that you could afford maybe or
something with your with your wife you
were inside so it was kind of like
savings by default a little bit because
the personal as you like to say the f b
budget had been you know held up by the
lockdown but Biden goes out and says hey
I've created all these jobs no it's not
it's all these people are coming back
all the hospitality workers that were
basically furloughed came back to their
hospitality jobs that's not a new job it
would be like this me and the business
doc babe have some trouble so we agree
to get counseling and we do a little
separation for three months while we get
counseling then on her birthday we
announced that we're back together and I
walk into a room full of people and say
hi I'd like you to meet my new wife
that is what Biden is just doing with
the jobs report that's hilarious though
but uh yeah so anyway so again you look
at the numbers so one side says things
are going to be okay the other side is
we're not going to be in recession look
at the numbers what's going to happen
the reality is nobody fully knows what
is going on okay everybody's purely
speculating including us but what Adam
said is where it goes slow drip drip I
thought at first it was going to get up
and start dancing like he was like doing
some kind of a song but he wasn't he was
gonna go and then all of a sudden boom
it drops and everybody says holy [__]
you know so and the opposite can happen
as well what's the opposite that all of
a sudden you wake up you're like how the
hell did Dow Jones get to 42 000 that is
the crazy part about the economy okay
that's why no one in the history of it
has been able to have a hundred percent
track record of guessing what happens
next okay it's a Gamble and and all this
just got highlighted over the last two
three years Market tanks Black Swan
event didn't see this happening shut
down everything's going down how much
did the stock market go down the first
six months of covet 40 whatever it was
boom bounce back higher than ever hit 30
000 first time ever yeah and we're
seeing these wild swings and numbers
personal savings rates higher than it's
ever been a year later lowest savings
rates I think I think we we we're not
fully appreciating how [__] insane
covid was from a money standpoint
discover a world shutdown standpoint
supply chain I think people get it but
we're finally just kind of trying to
make sense of these numbers and then
didn't Biden just announce that as of
May 2023 in the next few months
officially we're done is that what was
that announcement we see that at once
but this this is the done done this yeah
we're done it's like the Tom Brady
retirement again oh wink wink oh yeah
yeah yeah but yeah I think you're I
think you're right it's amazing he's
like okay now it's really done yeah
these wild swings and numbers I think
should be expected after such a
Blackstone event we just covered a lot
of different things right there let's go
to the next story here uh Tom Brady
retiring from football for good second
time run emotional message that he gave
I wore his jersey yesterday uh I don't
want to spend a lot of time on this
thing here but obviously seeing him make
the announcement uh and now taking a
break to go with the family nobody knows
what he's going to be doing next he's
already got a massive contract for
himself it's a Once in a Lifetime uh
player to see what he did seven
championships the argument becomes the
following is should we moving forward
say he is the Brady of that or should we
still say he is the Jordan of such and
such dude that's the biggest debate and
some people may even come in and say
wait a minute what you're talking about
is great but imagine being the greatest
player in the world of a sport that is
the most popular player sport in the
world which is soccer we should moving
forward say he is the message so what is
we have to we have to figure it out
right now the world has to follow okay
right now should we have to figure it
out okay we're going to set the stand
for everybody is it Brady Jordan or
Messi moving forward in in the world
because you're in soccer in the world in
the United States of America Brady or
Jordan
yeah I
I mean I grew up with Jordan so that was
my that's my guy so as far as like the
greatest greatest greatest of anything
it's MJ it's not even a question however
why do you say that
Brady left went to the Bucks and won a
Super Bowl with another team did Jordan
win a championship with the Wizards you
know what you're right Rob Michael
Jordan no no bueno you got me no you got
me wait I know what he's saying is
though but record-wise seven seven
championships went to a different team
to win I think the greatest in the world
is Messi I think in the United States I
gotta go with Jordan I'm sorry I'm a
Giants fan and we beat him twice or else
if it wasn't for the New York Giants
he'd have two more Rings FYI I'll tell
you that you're welcome I'll tell you
this we can have that debate that's
great these are all this is this is Goat
Mountain right here yeah there's only
one the most eligible bachelor in the
world at this point that guy Thomas
Brady yeah number one so he doesn't need
to be on Bumble he doesn't need to be on
tender not at all he is
he is the honey to the Beast guy I got
you guys the bee's knees an honest
question if he didn't retire
I mean if he did go with the retirement
the first one would he still be married
probably yes are you serious that was
obviously the final strip now yes that
was the straw that broke the camera you
know the same with the horses in the
camera I did a straw that broke the
camera I disagree by the way in in the
World of Sports
when a goat retires and they go from
that life to a day to day
they're not used to seeing each other as
much as a part of why it worked was
because it was a part-time marriage it's
a full-time commitment but it's a
part-time I like that you know marriage
and bodybuilding it happens in baseball
and basketball and football I mean pools
you know Jordan you know so you got so
many of them you go through very very
few of them uh stay together it's a very
hard thing and so Tom Brady with where
she was I have a feeling they were
having issues way before that on the way
they want to live different Lifestyles
and uh no I think uh I think either way
it would have just taken a little longer
that's my opinion but anyway because
you're saying Pat because that time
apart like with seasons for the average
person you can't have a season it'd be
cool like babe I need two months let me
tell you I gotta go Vinnie you know when
when when when somebody says something
like this they'll say man I would have
loved if I would have worked with uh
Elon Musk I would freaking killed it if
I would have worked under Steve Jobs I
would have freaking killed it you know
if I if I had a teammate Brady dude it
would have been awesome you know if I
was married to Tom Brady and I had a
husband like him oh dude I would do
anything for the guy right
and then let's just say you do and
you're working for Steve Jobs what do
you think Steve Jobs would do do you
think he would sit there and say let me
sell you the vision like where Apple's
going to be in the future one day and
one day we're gonna build this machine a
computer is gonna fit in a small little
case like this and you would say what a
Visionary or do you think Steve Jobs
would say you guys got six months to fit
this big ass box and this or your fire
period okay all right so the point is
like you want to work for Steve Jobs
until you work for Steve Jobs and you
say this guy's a freaking Tyrant right
the hell is the matter with it and then
so you you're like I'd love to marry Tom
Brady oh Tom that'd be so freaking and
all of a sudden boom you're you're
Gisele uh my beautiful model you know
married to the guy Tom Brady and like
hold the freaking [__] I want him to
obsess over me like all the other men
I've ever dated this guy loves football
more than me I can be with a guy like
that and chat I want to be with a guy
like this and he'd go with a you know
Jiu Jitsu guy that's uh got an
instructor who's got more time to spend
time with you and Tom Brady yeah there's
a lot of people that want to be guy with
people like this until you are with them
and they're like holy [__] maybe I
should have just married the other
school teacher and uh both of them don't
work by the way because you want the bad
boy and you want the school teacher and
that guy just doesn't exist okay anyways
that that was more like Iran I love no
but you're right you're right you know
yeah by the one Jen and I were dating I
told her I said baby if you want a nine
to five guy I'm not it
if we went to a uh uh we went to a
counselor
and it's one guy Christian counselor who
the church was sent to and have you
heard me tell the story so we go to this
counselor and I said so so tell me about
yourself yeah I'm uh you know my wife
and I've been married 33 years I'm
suppressed so if somebody can take
advice from I said what's your secret
sauce for your marriage working out for
33 years
we have had dinner every night at six
o'clock we've never missed it I believe
that's the key to success I said what
business are you in oh I'm a school
teacher how about your wife she's also a
school teacher I said you know it's so
awesome meeting you here it's a 200 babe
we gotta go yeah he was so uncomfortable
Jennifer Zone comes like babe just let's
at least that's a no babe there's
nothing we can talk here yeah we get in
the car says what was that all about I
said babe I'm not a school teacher I'm
not going to be home at six o'clock
dinner this is not the life you want
that at somebody else you don't we want
to go take over the world this is a very
different mentality but if you are that
person go pee it yeah it's beautiful I'm
just not a school teacher but I think
it's so important what you're saying
about having those conversations up
front like you established early and
often with Jen hey I'm not that nine to
five guy so what's the um
what's the famous quote where it says
men wear married women hoping that they
will never change and that Women Marry
men hoping that they will change and
then invariably they'll both be
disappointed I think it's very it goes
It goes men marry women hoping they
don't change and they do women marry men
hoping they change and they don't right
yeah and they both end up disappeared so
I think if you establish what you were
just talking about up front Hey listen
I'm not that nine to five guy that's six
o'clock dinner thing every night I'm
just shooting a freaking video by six
o'clock I might not be home till eight
so like this is the guy you're going to
marry are you comfortable with that yeah
because I don't seven years down the
road I want to be like why are you never
home it's like I told you that up front
yeah and and going up all your step
patches really really fast I think those
moments where you are like that time off
I'm not saying being away from your wife
forever but like that season that he's
gone and whatever I think it helps
because you know you're apart and then
when you see each other it's amazing but
if you're there every single day in the
person's face it's a little it's a
little too much yeah the fables never
match you know the fables and the
stories never match the reality and you
can read a lot of books and biographies
about Bezos about jobs uh I love the
story it was in the Forbes her Fortune
goes way back jobs is very frustrated By
A Thing Called mobile me remember about
12 15 years ago maybe longer than that
apple had a product called mobile me
it's not really working right hauls
everybody into a conference room who is
working on it
so there's like apparently about 100
people in there
and he points a product manager and he
says tell me
what mobile me
what the spec is what the product is
well mobile me is the game and he looks
at the guy and he said okay and they
said he said turn red and Steve Jobs
says well then why the flip doesn't it
do that you're done and he points to his
left to two people they are leading the
project and he leaves the conference
room ladies and gentlemen that is the
romantic view exactly exactly exactly oh
only if I you know you know but by the
way that whole concept about you are the
person you are the average of five
people you hang out with there's
typically the one guy in that group that
you don't like because he's constantly
challenging you and you most people
would have a very hard time being
friends with a guy like Steve Jobs it's
not a easy friendship it's good on the
outside it's tough on the inside I love
that point you made by the way but your
network is your net worth and you are
the combination of the five people but
it's usually one guy one guy that loves
it together one guy that holds it
together and Vinnie thank you for
holding us all together brother no
question by the way just so everybody
knows Vinnie is probably the the
I don't know no he's the second best
athlete in this room Vinnie's a
ridiculous athlete I don't understand
why you're so good and I was like how do
we I don't know where there's nine forms
of intelligence okay okay interpersonal
you're good with people intra personal
you're independently you're good by
yourself like you can spend time you
some people call you alone or you're not
you're just very confident you're
self-aware uh three uh numerical you're
good with numbers four musical you're
good with music five is spatial you can
go into a room and say you got to put
something here you got to put something
here you got to put something I would
put the window here I would put the
kitchen here I got zero spatial okay
when it comes down to okay then you have
a a uh kinesthetic which is body you're
very good with body you're that's you're
one of them that's uh athletically you
guys just naturally can do that and then
there's a few other ones that are out
there right but it's a natural
intelligence some people that just pick
up a ball can and they can play it and
by the way the same is true about people
who are not you ever heard somebody
watch somebody that played the same
sport God knows over and over over again
they still look weird it's like the guy
that takes salsa lessons for seven years
and he goes to a club and dances salsa
and you're like I swear to God this is
uncomfortable to watch
yeah and he's been doing it for seven
damn years and it's like a robotics
that they do it just doesn't make sense
that's not you anyway let's go to the
next story Rhonda Santos let's do around
DeSantis if you guys are okay with this
I don't want to upset anybody let's talk
about some uh Ron DeSantis here here we
go Ron DeSantis reportedly preparing for
2024 presidential run a more angry
Donald Trump takes shot at this loyal
Florida Governor this just happened uh
recently but I want to go to the most
updated story of
where the scientists uh uh there it is
the gloves are off Donald Trump Brands
2024 right around the sound very
disloyal uh uh where's the one that okay
there it is that's the one it says the
Santa's response to Trump's criticism
says verdict has been rendered by
Florida voters not holding back by the
way okay not holding back at all uh so
here's here's what it sounds like uh uh
uh former president Donald Trump has
come to Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
owes his success to Donald Trump's
Administration and that hypothetical
presidential bid would be insulting Ron
would have not been Governor if it
wasn't for me so when I hear he might
run I consider that very disloyed which
by the way he is right if it wasn't for
Trump's endorsement Ron doesn't win
governorship I mean whether you like
Trump or you like the scientist or
you're going to vote Republican Ticket
No Matter What or you don't like either
one of them that endorsement helped him
get he won by 34 000 votes the Santas
responded to Trump's comments by citing
his recent Landslide victory for with
Florida voters well look what I would
say uh would just say is this I roll out
of bed I have people attacking me from
all angles the Santa said and the good
thing is that the people are able to
render a judgment on that whether they
re-elect you or not the scientist was
overwhelmingly re-elected in November
for a second term leading Florida and
won the highest percentage of the vote
that any Republican governor candidate
has in the history of a state's history
he also won by the largest raw vote
margin of one and a half million votes
than any governor candidate has ever had
in the Florida history the verdict has
been rendered by the people of the State
of Florida okay which by the way you go
from winning by 34 000 votes and you go
winning one and a half million votes and
you win Miami day you win you mean date
you and this is what he did is
absolutely unbelievable to validate how
great of a job he did for four years but
that doesn't mean mean Trump's
endorsement didn't help him win and
without Trump's endorsement he wouldn't
want anyways Pat just going up because
he said he claimed that he you know he
owes him for the success I'm going to be
100 honest with you me living in
California not really in the political
world I didn't hear who I don't know the
governor of Florida I didn't know
anything about that Trump's attitude
towards the medium being bold and then
all of a sudden I did start seeing
DeSantis started becoming that guy where
I was like oh that oh my God he's kind
of like him where he's calling out the
you know pointing at people telling
reporters in their face I don't know if
it was the Trump like attitude or the
Mystique but that type of attitude I've
seen come like Harry Lake and all these
very interesting points isn't that weird
and this is coming from a guy that lives
in California that's a veteran that
never gave a damn about politics then I
started seeing covid and it was during
covet where DeSantis was like no no
we're not going to be like these people
and that Drew the attention to him
because he was Trump like you feel me so
I mean say what you want I think a
little bit of that attitude didn't brush
off on them the most impressive thing of
desantis's uh win for governor in 2022
was that he took Hillsborough County I
know Miami-Dade is often very much
liberal there is no more liberal county
in the state of Florida than Hillsboro
that's Tampa St Petersburg that is where
Charlie Crist resides that's his
hometown and he beat Charlie Crist by
how many votes 40 000 votes oh damn
so if you look at basically if you want
to give if you want to call each of
trump and DeSantis a stock yeah right
clearly one has been on the upswing
since 2020. obvious and one has been on
the major decline since 2020. um and
shots fired by the way because DeSantis
does not respond to Trump he takes it he
takes it he takes it but read into
exactly what he said and the good thing
is that the people are able to render a
judgment on that on whether they
re-elect you or not read between the
lines here he's basically saying I got
reelected by a landslide you did not
sorry to inform you and we often say
that if not for covid Trump would have
probably been re-elected 100 if not for
covid we probably wouldn't all know Ron
desantis's name I agree with you you
don't know the random Governor from a
state it doesn't matter no the reality
is kovid was uh Trump's Achilles heel
and kovid was what made Ron DeSantis I
agree so we'll see what happens right
now at this point if you look at the
numbers you know I'm a big Vegas guy
it is now the Santa's election to lose
wow he's passed Trump in the primary
polls and we'll see what happens but
we've got a long road ahead no doubt but
but here's the thing though love them or
hate them don't you think just being
Trump wouldn't you be furious if from
even before you got in or you got called
that you won the Department of Justice
with the FBI with Peter struck and all
these freaking guys with Hillary Clinton
all colluding the actual collusion was
the left and then bro that all that
presidency and then covet everybody
every the whole swamp against you don't
you think he kind of wants to come in
and have a shot where all that [__] is
already done and you could be like all
right I'm coming in wrong now you guys
can't play that Russia [__] again all
the all the all the colluding all that
[__] no no now I'm coming in without all
you guys all the Deep State behind me I
mean I would be a pissed off number one
but number two I would tell the people
hey guys how about give me a shot
without everybody against me let me yeah
I'm gonna talk [__] yeah I'm gonna be
Brash but give me a chance you know what
I mean because be honest it wasn't fair
it wasn't love him or hate him it wasn't
fair and then covet comes I mean how
much [__] could go wrong for one guy be
honest I hear you I hear you you're
making a good case here but I think this
is one thing I will say there's nothing
uglier than politics obvious
presidential politics so when you enter
the ring you know exactly it's gonna be
a mud slinging contest Galore you don't
think DeSantis is literally emotionally
spiritually mentally getting ready God
bid you run
every disgusting thing you've ever done
is gonna be exposed what was great about
Trump is talk about ten flout Dawn
anyone grab them by the police they're
done they're yeah they're cancer in
their campaign no more ammo he's like
hell yeah I did that locker room talk
buddy so yeah it's a dirty dirty game
you better be ready but when your own
government and the Department of Justice
as you're a sitting president is
illegally going by and then nothing
happens to them welcome to politics
I get it it's horrible but no but but
you're 100 right Donald nobody's been
shot he's wounded he has like what else
can you say about me bro Stormy Daniels
yeah by the way before the Stormy
Daniels lawyer whatever happened to that
guy whatever happened with him do you
have any thoughts on this or no yeah I
think you know
I see it both ways I I look at I look at
Trump and I say look here's a guy that
used his personal political Capital you
know whether you love him or hate him he
used his personal political Capital to
help Ron DeSantis at a key time and Ron
DeSantis is not governor and does not
launch the bigger phase of his political
life without that endorsement and
Trump is saying listen I lost but I'm
going to get ahead of seem I'm going to
get the band back together uh some will
be with me some won't but I'm going to
get it back together and I'm going to
run again and I think he's told
everybody that in Whispers
and he is disappointed that DeSantis is
putting together a campaign to go run
unfortunately this is not you know
King's X this is not the way it works I
mean you look at the you look at the the
Democrat field Hillary was running I am
running and I'm gonna go and everybody
stay out of the way nope Obama ran all
those people stepped up when it's time
to run for president it's a Adam you're
it's the way to say it it is such a
dirty game and you have to keep
reminding yourself as you analyze it
this is Dirty by Design right say how
Hillary's like I was Secretary of State
I'm smart as hell I had the first
Healthcare initiative I have all these
things stay the flip out of my way no
there was nine people on stage with her
an Obama beat her
um
and you know that just that's just the
way this works yeah Pat let me ask you
you I think you've only watched one
Netflix show ever
from beginning to end well Greg sure
told me to watch Ted lasso because okay
what was your season one okay okay so
that's the only show you've ever watched
House of Cards
which essentially that's Kevin Spacey by
the way what happened to him he gets
sexual assault charges and nothing he'll
never go he's Untouchable where I'm
going with this is I think if anybody
understands how dirty business is and
you know everything you're working on
with you know your enemies and all that
not that you needed to watch House of
Cards to really fully fundamentally
realize how disgusting and dirty
politics is but how dirty did you did
you think it was is it what are you
seeing out there everything that using
your house of cards as a reference point
to business the dirtiness of politics
compared to business if you want well I
I don't know I'm not in it you know I'm
not in the political world but when I'm
you know in the business world it's very
ugly but at least in the business World
there are some laws and regulation these
guys are using laws in regulation as
like the way many of these politicians
that I've been around they're no
difference than the guys who were in New
York saying hey you know the Gambino
family protects our restaurant hey you
mess with us you got to go talk to the
Colombo family hey you got to go to such
and such family and they're like hey
Tony I'm sorry man don't worry I'm good
please tell Sammy we're okay we don't
have any issues you want me to call
Sammy no no you don't I'm good totally
good the way these guys are running
politics is they're saying oh you want
to say something you want me to contact
you want me to get okay no problem see
what I do with IRS is the Gambino family
doj is the Colombo family yeah you know
you got the FBI is the Genovese family
you want me to keep going like they got
these five families I'm gonna call one
of the families and look what we're
gonna do too we're going to ruin your
life is what we do and that's what they
do so they're they're a bunch of ponds
that lean on to those five families to
destroys people's lives and they're very
very good at it so this is why when you
run for office we can have a good time
together
all right so let's go to the next story
so let's go to the next story let's go
to the next story Republican Nikki Haley
is set to announce a run for president
Nikki Haley is set to announce a run for
president
uh Nikki Haley a former South Carolina
governor who also served in the Trump
Administration is preparing a run for
2024 the Republican is set to be the
first to challenge former president
Donald Trump on a GOP Primary Election
Haley served as Trump's U.S ambassador
to the United Nations for nearly two
years from 2017-2018 when she resigned
prior to her tenure in the Trump
Administration Haley led the state of
South Carolina as the Governor from 2011
to 2017 when she left to take the job at
the U.N Haley was the first woman to
serve as governor of South Carolina in
2021 Haley has said she wouldn't run for
president if Trump ran again but
recently deviated from her typical line
calling for a new generation of
leadership in the Republican party in an
appearance on Fox news that she later
posted on Twitter so Nikki Haley what
are your thoughts on Nikki Haley running
for president well I think there's two
things so I want to talk about uh macro
micro because you know that's how I do
it on the macro level she has now come
out and there's more than just the sanus
has walked onto the debate stage there's
now three podiums Trump DeSantis and
Haley this opens the door for others to
declare as well
on the macro stage and so what that does
this actually helps the sanus because
it's not DeSantis breaking Rank and
saying I want to run now it's multiple
people and it's like hey this is a
primary this is what we do this is the
process so Donald you're going to be on
stage and uh there's other people going
to be there so on the macro level I
think this helps DeSantis because it
opens up the field and it's not just
Trump versus DeSantis there's many
people running the second thing on the
micro level I think she's positioning
for a VP spot oh wow that's my that's my
thought what do you think Pat um you and
I on the same page with that I I think
what they are doing uh is exactly that
yeah that's for me it's exactly that uh
uh they're they're speaking very highly
of each other when you get on that stage
the strategy my opinion is the fact that
Nikki Haley is going to be the one to go
after DeSantis not Trump and digging a
double tag team and then eventually
Nikki could end up being a VP and by the
way she's a very qualified VP if she
ends up becoming a VP some even thought
at one point she wasn't on Trump Camp
because she called him out on a couple
different things so this is you know
this is a very very strategy strategic
thing that's taking place it's going to
be interesting to see the Camp that
because there is a republican camp that
doesn't want Trump and there is a
republican Cam that only believes
Trump's the one that needs to finish up
his second term and fix everything that
started either way this is not what
we're seeing strategy taking place
between the two it'll be fun to see what
direction the sentence this was an
episode I sort of got on House of Cards
where where uh Kevin Spacey's character
teamed up with somebody else during a
debate and I mean I I say it all plan
but dude honestly I'm one just hearing
you guys talk about the stage and the
well I swear to God I would pay to watch
I'm excited to see that moment of
DeSantis Trump and her I think that UFC
get on board bro and just make it like
announce them and have them come in dude
I I would 100 put 50 bucks to watch this
but the first time I still need to put
our bet on it that's going to divide the
party and then we mean you've uh pay for
what I think I think Tom hit it on the
head I think Pat agreed with him she is
full on auditioning for a vice
presidential role in the movie called
2024. there's no chance she's being
elected president of the United States
no okay my opinion hear me I agree it's
Trump or DeSantis that's it okay by the
way she ain't no like walk in the park
she's cunning smart smart attractive
enough to to basically hold her own on
this stage she was a governor wasn't she
the ambassador to the U.N under Trump
like she no joke so just House of card
Style
she's got some stuff up herself let's
see who she attacks let's see if she
Embraces and it's not just up her sleeve
it's between her ears um I I had that
privilege of sitting with her and with
um uh congresswoman Beth Van Dyne in
Dallas at a small gathering they were
trying to raise funds and stuff and she
was there to support Beth's campaign and
there was about 50 of us at this little
reception before the big reception you
know how those things work
um and somebody asked her to give a
breakdown of you know foreign trade
tariff no tariff and things and she went
for 15 minutes with one of the most
elegant dissertations and I'm like wow
not only does she know what she's
talking about she's in it and that was
when she was serving at the U.N so this
is also a very smart person that would
balance a ticket and she would play her
foreign policy cards and experience her
trade in the U.N her and DeSantis
unbeatable ticket her and Trump still
very beatable my opinion what you might
be right wait her and descent is
unbeatable ticket her and Trump
still to be yeah
because I think bottom line is this
we're talking about primaries we get it
there's so many Independents out there
there's so many you know conservative
Democrats who will gladly loudly proudly
walk into a voting booth and say I voted
for Ron DeSantis no doubt there's not
those many of those to Trump these days
I'm Sorry by the way we went over 6 500
live I'm just wondering so here's what I
just did I just send a text message to
the people that originally signed up for
the podcast okay they just got an email
with the link to the event by the end of
the podcast I'm going to send the link
to everybody here those guys got a 45
minute uh Head Start Head Start and then
we'll do the live podcast so yeah uh and
and let me some people are asking a
question about Stephen Crowder let me
tell you guys what happened with Stephen
Crowder Stephen Crowder we had in the
past try to get him on the podcast Rob I
think we reached out a couple times in
the past correct and then after the
video he did call on our daily wire uh
his Camp reached out saying Stephen
Crowder would like to come on the
podcast we said yeah no problem we
scheduled for a Wednesday
to be on the podcast
and uh that uh Monday morning or Sunday
uh we got an email saying well a family
emergency took place and he can't be
here which we sell us and family
emergency happens we understand it uh
you know maybe we can do it earlier or a
different day now he can't do it it's a
major family emergency he can't be there
no problem
then what was very uh interesting is
that even though there was a family
emergency that Monday
after the family emergency was on
Temple's podcast okay
so uh you go on Tim post podcast but you
tell us there's a family emergency that
happened specifically on Wednesday but
you can do because typically when it's a
family emergency you may be taking a few
days off so here's all I will say guys
we've dealt with presidents we've dealt
with billionaires we've dealt with uh
the athletes Kobe Bryant's Kevin Hart
we've dealt with like AAA listers which
everybody that becomes an a-listers
everybody is typically doing what what
can we do for you accommodate your
Heroes and all this other stuff right
and we've never had a person that
cancels like that and just says hey you
know and then later on the email comes
well we can't do it right now maybe
later on you'll be the first for us to
talk and we don't play those games we
don't like those games so there is a
part of it where you think some of the
critics criticism that he got if it was
real or not we don't know again I've
never spoken to him I've never had a
call with them I've never had a sit down
with them
we were more than happy to uh uh to have
a civil conversation here to see what
took place with a guy like that but for
those of you that are fans of his that
were expecting him to be here they
canceled last minute due to family
emergency and still went on Tim pull
podcasts on that Monday instead of a
Wednesday we are not sitting here saying
we know what the emergency was or not
I'm just telling you I'm not accustomed
to a family emergency taking place yet
you go to a different podcast on a
Monday so that is for the people that
are asking about Crowder now having said
that uh James O'Keefe was scheduled to
be here today James and I are texting
right now each other we are trying to
get him to be on the podcast tomorrow we
don't know if it's going to happen or
not we got to get him on a flight he's
coming from a different place
undisclosed location and we got to get
him in here so if you see us having a
podcast tomorrow with James O'Keefe it
may happen so but I can't guarantee you
until James is sitting here and there's
two other big massive names we're
working on that reached out to us to be
on the podcast we won't announce it
until it happens moving forward once we
know we'll uh uh we'll let you know when
we're going live with these guys there's
a lot of interesting people I had a very
very very interesting call with somebody
yesterday who is
extremely uh um uh a name that everybody
knows a name that say that we're working
on some big projects as well to
potentially come on the podcast but
we'll see what's going to happen with
calendar were you going to say something
I just wanted to address back to the
Stephen Crowder thing I don't know do we
want to get into what happened with Ben
Shapiro and all that I mean it's very
public at this point sure go forward
yeah but I I guess
what are the details of what happened I
I there's things you follow and there's
things you follow kind of you know
peripherally I saw what was going on but
I what I did see was Ben Shapiro's
response he was not happy
he was not happy whatsoever what was
your take on Shapiro Crowder daily wire
what exactly happened so let me let me
give you a this disclaimer so everybody
knows I don't have a relationship with
Ben Shapiro him and I have done one
interview together was fascinating you
guys a brilliant mind but we don't text
we don't talk we haven't spoken to him
no conversations the same with Candace
Owens the same with Jeremy boring any of
that stuff there's been zero
communication with them at all an
invitation to the podcast zero none of
that stuff in the last however long it's
been we've had zero conversations with
those guys uh I think they're very
necessary I think they're very talented
I thought Jeremy boring to go through
the entire contract was uh extremely
bold extremely confident to do it uh you
know you and that that's Ben Shapiro's
partner for those because he's not a
household name everyone knows is a
household name in this space the guy is
a heavyweight legit a type of a guy that
you would want to have as a president
CEO c-suite CEO he's the guy he used to
be partners I believe years ago with a
guy named Zach Levi Zach Levi is the
underdog movie of Kurt Warner Zach Levi
is what he called the the Shazam guy the
good-looking guy yeah so this is not a
lightweight guy this guy right here he
went after Gillette in a way that was
freaking okay so now as you were yeah
yeah so so both of these guys and by the
way on the other side Stephen Crowders
may be uh at the top of the list of like
who Bill Maher is at the top of the left
probably Crowder is at the top of the
right to be the comedian doing what he
does so Crowder is a absolute some will
put him at the top above everybody uh on
the comedy and political side debating
anyone he's expensive I learned about
yeah so there's that part and there's a
massive but here's what's going to
happen when a Crowder makes a claim like
that yeah and you record and then Ben
Shapiro goes after why would you record
your friend and you know who's going to
trust to do business with anybody when
you record somebody everybody that walks
into a room with Stephen Crowder is
going to be like this guy's probably
recording the conversation that's on
everybody's mind now moving forward when
you do something like that so it's tough
when you do business with someone like
that it's chance so that's what the call
out is on the other side so here's the
part yeah here's the part
Stephen Crowder now
when you go out there and you declare
your intentions as publicly as he did
you best back it up
you best back it up so here's the
problem
March of 09 I'm sitting down with a man
named Bill I told them after dinner we
had with George Will I want to announce
my mission statement that saving America
and bring him back the free enterprise
system and hope to American families
he says this is the mission statement of
the company says yes he says don't do it
I said why is that he says if you do
this how are you going to be doing it I
said well I'm going to work with
middle-income families I'm going to work
with minorities I'm going to teach them
about sales business capitalism Finance
Insurance how money works I'm going to
help these guys have the mentality of a
winner competitor discipline why
immigrants come here to capitalistic
mentality The Immigrant mentality that's
what we're going to be doing he says if
you do that who's going to be coming to
I'm planning on having the the
president's come to our even Senators
Governors people who understand Finance
economists comptrollers billionaires I
want comedians Kobe I want all these
guys to come he says here's my
suggestion to you if you say something
like that from stage in front of Pulpit
okay which the event was called save in
America doing the impossible was dressed
as a uh George Washington you can type
in George Washington Patrick David maybe
a picture will show up on Google and I
get up and I said we're going to be
doing this he says don't do it unless
you're 100 committed to it I said what
do you mean he says don't do it unless
if you're 100 committed to it uh uh a
video of it is somewhere around there
that you can find if you can pause it
and not have the audio that's a fast
forward a little bit fast forward a
little bit fast forward a little bit
that's me in general
right there okay so here's the thing you
are the smallest brownest George
Washington that I've ever seen so he
tells me he tells me
by the way by the way the year before I
was dressed as George C Scott given the
patent speech for five minutes which is
a pretty epic speech okay I hope
whoever's got to send him my way I want
to see it it's been 15 16 years but he
says don't
say that mission statement
unless you 100 mean it and you're going
to go out there and Advance towards it
he scares the crap out of me I step away
I don't announce it I said I'm not doing
it oh really 30 days goes by 60 I can't
sleep at night I'm so worried about it
then the day comes July 17th that event
I get up and I announce the vision
mission what we're going to be doing in
July of 09 okay
I announce it to everybody everybody is
flipping five this is JW Marriott in
Palm Springs everybody's fired up you
know who's not fired up I'm not fired up
because I went to sleep saying holy [__]
I better freaking do it yeah so then you
see David Walker the Comptroller general
of us comes to the event and I interview
him then you see we bring Santorum then
president shows up then Kobe shows up
then Kevin Hart shows up then
everybody's and then the events goes
from 500 people to a thousand people to
2 000 people and five thousand people
MGM Grand Arena you were there we're
putting concerts with Nelly with Nikki
jam with Sebastian Maniscalco with Mario
Lopez as the MC with Shaq all this stuff
and then it turned into what it is today
and now people say well what Pat said he
did in the insurance space this is not
public information this is in the
insurance space on what I did and then
value Timmy kind of made some of this
stuff be public Crowder has to back it
up now and it sucks every night he goes
to sleep everybody's saying where is it
who are you signing what are you doing
you just put yourself on blast you put
daily wire on blast who are you signing
this who are you giving a contract to
next what are you going to be doing
that's where he's at if he does it guess
what you got to do to Crowder salute if
he doesn't do it you got to say daily
wire was right wow that's a lot of
pressure and welcome to the world of
competition because it freaking sucks
he's been in it for a while and he's
dominated as a talent yeah
but it's a very different game to go
from a talent to running a company last
night we had our annual uh virtual Gala
at the other event the building a
federal and we had you know 10 plus
thousand people on a live Zoom with us
watching and we're recognizing all the
MVPs etc etc and at the end we were
having conversations about the the
business during covet what happened me
and one of our guys
uh co-founders George were talking and I
was telling some of the things that
happened with the company the challenge
of dealing with W-2 is you realize
there's a difference between being a
great salesperson there's a difference
between being a great sales leader doing
10.99 with an assistant there's a
difference between a startup founder
there's a difference with growing a
company with employees and States
regulations taxes you're paying on 49
different states and department of
insurance and 49 different states
legality Eno [__] [__] legal law
compliance it's very very annoying so
you can be a very good salesperson and
suck as a sales leader you can be a
great sales leader and suck as a CEO
absolutely suck as a CEO this thing is
hard so Crowder can be a very good
Entertainer and a comedian and suck as a
seal running a company yeah or he may be
great if he does salutations to you so
anyways that's what happened with
Crowder so if we can continue we got a
lot of others I have one quick follow-up
because by the way kudos to everything
you just said right there what I just
wanted pinpoint real quick is
the advisor Crowder you took this advice
and you I saw everything you're saying
makes complete sense what I want to ask
is one specific thing when the guy who's
the guy that said hey be careful don't
do this don't make this announcement
think before you do it who was that guy
Bill Bill Vogel okay so bill so you have
this Vision you have this plan you have
this idea you have this company you want
to start and you said you're in bed
you're tossing attorney 30 days 60 days
what was it that you were unsure of and
what kind of clarity did you get to say
all right I'm doing it now okay July
17th what changed very simple why are
you not married with kids
[Laughter]
same exact thing okay what Clarity no no
why are you not married with kids
we do a whole hour podcast no it's one
word
it's one word
there's no other words bro it's the
scariest word in the world commitment
responsibility [__] yeah bro that weight
is so heavy are you kidding me marriage
you know what kind of responsibility
comes with risk freaking being married
or kids are you out of your mind to have
one two three risk four five it is very
hard so the same fear men you and I have
yeah of being married and having kids is
the same fear and anxiety we have of
saying you want me to say I'm
responsible for this Mission and this
Vision Vision this is a little too much
man I don't know and then you're praying
you're talking you're walking you're
trying to because it's you can't talk to
your wife you can't talk to your
you know and by the way at the time I
was single I wasn't married yet okay you
can't talk to anybody at the time you
can't go to your dad and say what do you
think about this mission of saving
America he's like what's saving America
saved a bit David family who cares about
America
that's hilarious so anyways but the
point is it's a very lonely place to be
when you want to cast a vision like that
so anyways about that is is that you
took your time to make that decision and
that announcement
scary scary thought man so anyways
that's the idea with uh Stephen Crowder
and some of you guys with James O'Keefe
hopefully we'll get a chance to get them
on tomorrow to find out what's going on
with uh all this stuff with Pfizer did
you see what he did with that video that
video on Twitter we've got 26 million
views then you know what he does he goes
and rents I don't want to play the video
because we'll play tomorrow we'll talk
about it he goes and rents a truck
playing the video on all angles and
Parks it in front of Pfizer's
headquarters that's a massive troll bro
we gotta we gotta
on a Pfizer's headquarters man you gotta
be born there's an idea for us we can
work on this we need to put together a
top 10 troll in the world thing oh yeah
we got Elon there we got Jake Paul there
James O'Keefe is in the top ten no doubt
at this point he's on down here guys you
guys a question in regards to that video
where you put by the way the text we
just sent the event's about to sell out
I know it sells that this is why you
wanted to be on the text list if the
event's about to sell a Cayenne uh
what's the date of your text message
it's gonna be February 23rd February
23rd but keep going so so project
Veritas James will keep they expose that
guy I mean they've been exposing people
left and right for that's that's their
thing right so they get this guy then
the video on YouTube why does YouTube
take it down because it was coven
misinformation I don't know because you
know YouTube clicked on that video the
video had how many millions of views
well we'll find out tomorrow no I I yeah
no exactly and then Pat when you see
stuff like that when you see people
getting signs what happened to America's
like our anger our things where we would
like go in the streets like when you see
stuff in Brazil those people when
they're pissed bro they go into the
freaking streets when you see Iran
they're in the streets what happened to
us what happened to Americans well
Americans were like you see something
like it's in your face Pfizer the
government all these people are are all
together to just screw us when it comes
to our health and all this nobody he
makes this video and he's like it's in
your face guys they're cool they're
really colluding all this [__] with
Pfizer and the government and the the
the nothing happens well you know you
you you have to know there's a many more
people who feel the same way as you do
but they don't know what to do okay they
don't know what to do if this video got
25 million views yeah there's 25 million
people interested in a story like that
that are it's not 25 million views it's
how many people share it like just watch
it with five people six people who
shared it yeah so really 25 million is
probably a hundred million people that
saw this so impacts being made and he's
making people's life harder but we'll
see what's going to happen there let's
continue let's go to Chachi BT I know
you got some thoughts on that right
there yeah so uh Chad gbt and AI driven
investment fund powered by IBM Watson
supercomputers quietly beating the
market by nearly 100 percent and Chad
gbt banned by New York University to
prevent plagiarism and then there's
another story that just came out about
teachers Rejoice Chad gbt creators have
released a tool to help detect AI
generated writing this is an Insider
story specifically for parents and
here's what it is since this launch LGBT
has caused shock waves in many
Industries due to its skilled writing
encoding abilities the bot has already
accomplished several impressive Feats
including passing the U.S medical
licensing exempt A Wharton MBA exam and
four Law School courses however Chad gbt
has also caused handwriting among
teachers and other education
professionals who say the bot will help
students get better at cheating and
plagiarism on Tuesday the company
launched a web-based program called AI
text classifier to tackle the issue the
program will flag paste it in text
uh with the following labels very
unlikely unlikely unclear if it is
possibly or likely AI generated anyways
so this is to help with the teachers but
again what are you going to do with that
there's very likely that you did that or
unlikely it's going to be kind of weird
but what are your thoughts on what's
going on with Chachi Beach I think with
chat gbt Pat just with Automation in in
general it scares the hell out of me
because it's slowly but surely like like
Amazon's laying off thousands Microsoft
is laying off thousands McDonald's
laying off thousands it's gonna
eliminate half the workforce robots are
going to take over so if you're in high
school or your kids are in high school
you better have them learn a trade that
a robot can't steal from them do you
understand what I'm talking about
doctors uh you're fine Engineers you're
going to be good but if it's something a
robot's doing bro you better find
something your Niche that's different
like thank God we're in the
entertainment world I mean until a robot
can make people laugh and write and that
which will be I'll be dead by then
figure out something because and I think
it's scary Pat all those people are
gonna be losing all those jobs they're
going to be trying to look for food and
it's poverty it's going to be in the
next 20 years bro it's going to be scary
as [__] because they're taking over the
jobs that all these people are like ah
they're not really trying to upgrade and
get better because now it's a really big
shift because I don't remember Pat I
remember as a kid this is how old I am I
was watching TV and I would see www dot
that's when the website the internet
started I was like what the hell why are
they putting it on everything and then
not look where we are right now is that
age for that robotic chat gbt and all
this my our friend Mike Mike that works
here showed me this and it's what it's
doing it's mind-boggling so you better
tell your kids tell yourself figure out
something that an iRobot type of machine
can't can't take over because it's
coming and it's coming fast it's scary
yeah I mean look there's a there's a
camp that is part of your Camp that's
afraid what's going to happen in the
future that a lot of jobs are going to
be stolen and taken and there's a camp
that thinks this is going to create the
new jobs and we're going to have to
learn new skill sets there's a article
that came out from Harvard Business
review that said anybody you hire today
within 18 months has to learn 10 new
skill sets meaning things are changing
so Rob you're typing your mykia so every
yeah there it is uh uh no that's not the
one there's another article that says uh
Executives it's something about
Executives that Executives have to learn
10 new skill sets every 18 months
whoever you hire today doesn't yet have
the skill sets for the job that's going
to be needed in 18 months wow so that's
just the the only problem today is going
to be the following here's a problem
those who take their time to learn a
thing that we had to learn today will be
left behind your your ability to adapt
and learn quickly if you don't you will
pay a price for it that is the only
thing those folks will pay a price a lot
of changes are coming and it's constant
and it ain't slowing down so but we're
going to see what's going to happen yeah
no I just there's the I'm not even sure
if Vinnie's in that camp but he kind of
it pled his case for that camp I'm in
the other camp
um the market will figure out what the
market will do I mean I think that camp
that Vinnie's kind of describing is the
Andrew Yang Camp Technology's taking our
jobs we're going to need Ubi we're going
to need to print money people stay home
we got to work because technology taking
your job if there's anything we learned
during covet is that just printing free
money and paying people to stay home
doesn't exactly work well I think uh
much like how the internet people kind
of were saying this in 2000 why 2K the
internet's taking our jobs we don't need
it it's like well things are fun I think
con uh capitalism free enterprise
um inventing Reinventing Reinventing
Yourself pivoting A wise man once said
out work out improve out strategize
Outlast the Market's going to be
changing and I think it's your job to
improve get better learn new skill sets
and utilize technology to help you
improve rather than being scared of
technology so you know I'm utilizing
chat GPT just to come up with
copywriting and to come up with the
ideas or titles and I'm using that to my
advantage I'm not worried that they're
taking jobs necessary so just keep
improving you know it's amazing you said
that years ago a guy told me because I
used to love shining my shoes I used to
love ironing my clothes I mean I love
ironing clothes and you know I love it
you know the main stars I love it cheap
ones I used to love it right and one guy
says you know that's a 10 an hour job
you're doing right there how do you
expect to make millions and you're doing
10 an hour job right what Chad gbt does
is it just showed you that job that used
to be worth 55 000 is no longer a 55 000
Auto job now somebody else can do it no
different than somebody that does you
your shoes or your suit or your haircuts
how come you don't learn how to cut your
own hair how come you don't know how to
because somebody else can do that this
is not an insult that is a job that
someone else can do and there are many
jobs that others were doing that
technology is going to start doing go
ahead Tom yeah I see three things I
first of all I agree with you 100 uh
there's three things I say on chat GPT
first of all it's plagiarism second of
all is jobs and third is New Frontier
under plagiarism you know this is always
comes around but it always gets solved
I'll give you an example teachers were
concerned about Wikipedia oh kids can
just go on the internet take the mouse
cut and paste all the stuff and make a
little term paper up by putting their
own voice on it and then editing a
little bit that was true well guess what
capitalism struck entrepreneurs struck
Chegg chedg.com and dupla Checker are
used by teachers in schools all over the
place and I require you to send in your
uh your term paper digitally they were
run it through check check comes back
yeah this is plagiarize this is
plagiarize this is here here it's very
effective and guess what it's resulted
in because of the presence of the
capitalist tool giving teachers the
ability to check guess what they did use
Wikipedia they put in the bibliography
as a source but they're still writing
their term papers the same thing is
happening now they're going to put tools
together to say hey you know what this
isn't this is this is AI generation and
this is how it it how it how it happens
and so
plagiarism and the bizdoc Babe tells me
all about this she says tools always
show up to all the teachers because the
school's just the most concerned about
it the second thing is jobs it's just
changing there look there are robots
that are welding together cars now and
all the scare and everything oh this is
going to eliminate Factory workers UAW
is going to lose workers well guess what
it those workers are doing different
things now and there are robots putting
that together oh we want 15 an hour you
know minimum wage in New York suddenly
McDonald's Had kiosks apparently built
by the same company that builts out with
Airlines kiosk and by the way the kiosk
showed up at airports and there was less
workers at the desk to do anything other
than take your bags it's just a rotation
of the economy the jobs it's just a
rotation the tide comes in the tide
comes out and in terms of New Frontiers
that's right a 55 000 a year for you
know a marketing person writing copy
suddenly becomes you know maybe a
seventy thousand dollar a year somebody
managing and using chat DBT to write it
and so I I think this is just another
example a technology comes up there's
fear but then there's acceptance and
utilization and understanding that it
all keeps working forward personally you
know I want things to keep growing
toward the future because we talked at
the beginning of this about has the
first person been born that will live to
150 years why is that because of
medicine because of research because of
the time in which we live not because
that they could get a toothache in 1915
that could go septic and kill them right
this is all part of the the wave of how
technology actually makes life better
don't be afraid of it embrace it go do
something with it by the way let's just
go on today I just comment on one thing
Todd said uh Tom said because I fully
agree with what you're saying and and
sometimes the wisdom of Tom does gets
overlooked because he talks so fast and
like I just got so much stuff and I
wrote down some notes here's what I'm
saying you you said sometimes the tide
comes in the tide comes out just like
you know what goes up must come down
here's what I'll tell you the the return
of old school is kind of happening when
all this technology you're presented
with what in school now they're going to
make you do handwritten essays no longer
digital stuff you have to do it okay
dating apps we've realized oh that's
great but you know what's even better
meeting up in real life yeah what's
crazy Bitcoin it's a digital crypto it's
like you know what's better cash so like
this this reset just kind of the tide
going out tied coming back in I think is
fully a great example Todd that's I
agree old school was a great movie and
that was a very you know
real quick okay yeah
yeah so vinyl sounds pretty good has I
like contracts has first person to live
to be 150 years old been born this is a
Harvard Gazette story David Sinclair
scientist and aging expert and director
of Harvard Medical Schools Paul F Glenn
Center for biology of Aging research was
asked about his previous statement on
the possibility of someone living to 150
he responded by saying over the last 20
years there have been a number of
molecules that have been found to
um
is that really the word he says
do you see the word to uh uh what page
around right there over the past to the
the is that the article right there yes
over the past 20 years has been a how do
you pronounce it is what I say the aging
process the scientific term that's weird
yeah it's a slow you don't use it okay
I'm gonna say it in Psychology you would
say [__] which is bad and especially
if you're looking at somebody if you're
not using in a clinical sense cancel the
other word no the other word is [__]
like [__] it's [__] so [__] yeah
retardant yeah that's exactly right he
was a [__] like uh like uh what do you
call it uh yeah at least
a couple of drugs that aren't humans
that made me optimistic that somebody
who might make it to 150 has already
been born in this chapter we're shown at
the possibility to reset the age of the
body up to as much as 50 percent uh uh
we can reverse aging in other issues
tissues as well if you can reset the age
of the body multiple times I think it
would be dangerous to set an upper limit
I think it's inevitable he concluded
with these Technologies are developing
now and the speed of development is
getting faster and faster so I don't
think it's far away that people will
live up to 150 years old and I'll finish
up with the store because they go kind
of together from Jeff pays us to Jack
Dorsey here's 14 world's wealthiest
entrepreneurs trying to crack the code
of living forever okay Peter Theo Larry
Ellison Larry Page Siri Sergey brain
Mark Zuckerberg Sean Parker
Dorsey Bezos Yuri Milner Dimitri izakov
David Murdoch Robert G Miller Brian
Johnson and wojakov key all of these
guys are trying to so 150 years old Tom
150 years old first of all I know you're
dealing with an anti-aging company right
now the project don't don't say anything
until you finalize you told me I was
shocked to even I don't like the fact
that you're willing to be tested for it
I applaud I wouldn't have done it you
saw but you so you you're the one that
sent me the article that said that I
said I said it's up to but it's you
gotta risk it I'm not going to tell you
to risk it you got to decide whether you
want to take that risk and I know you're
still thinking about it it's a reverse
agent but we'll see what happens okay
Tom would you want to live to 150 years
old
um
no I think people are going to want to
tap out of this life long before that
um with with a lot that's going on no no
would I would I like to live you know
what you know I'll live the years that
God gives me and if it turns out I'm
born into a time that I'll live to 150 I
want to do as much as I can with each
moment uh you've already heard me say I
personally don't want to retire you know
I want to teach I want to keep working I
have no desire to get a metal detector
and walk up and down the beach looking
for somebody else's wedding ring you
know not a visual what a visual where we
live in South Florida so you can kind of
see a couple of those guys I love it hey
Patrick I found a watch today all right
Adam 150 would you want to live up to
one I think uh life is precious and I
think you know the longer you live like
I have a goal I want to get to 100
that's just me you know 150 God bless I
think I don't remember who it was I
don't know if it was Neil deGrasse Tyson
or who was exactly and they said the
problem with wanting to live that long
is that you know procrastination is the
killer of success and if you know that
you're gonna have a long life and you've
got 150 years to get stuff done you'll
sleep in a little bit longer you'll hit
that snooze button Antonio Robbins I
think gave an amazing speech about this
like stop chasing your dreams stay in
bed just stay in your lane yeah take a
nap so I think you know if you are going
to live that old that you you kind of
not have motivation and procrastination
if I'm gonna look like that Pat there's
no way in hell
hell 150 what's up with the guy top left
he looks like he's doing what's up with
that guy he's killing him people are
bringing you you realize that that guy
was 146 yeah he claimed to be 146. is
that a bullet in his mouth or would is
that a tooth what is that oh look he got
it it's a bullet
yeah here's my thing Pat and at that age
at that age I mean unless you're it's
very keeping up the great oh very ten
but like you're now a burden on other
people because you're not going anywhere
by yourself people are carrying you and
you're an ordeal now they're like Pat's
coming yeah get the chair get the IV get
the put the blind something yeah okay
God comes to you yeah you're 75 years
old it says
Vinnie yes God
you're 75. yep you finally have really
retired because she what Social Security
was 65 it was 70. can you do this in
James Earl Jones uh both just to be yeah
very Vinnie yeah this is God yes yeah hi
god well done you've lived 75 years and
now they've let you retire on Social
Security thank you I'm giving you
another 75 just to think about the first
75. I don't want that gun there we go
I'm good I'm actually a good guy yeah I
don't know I I don't know all right yes
I'm good I'm good if I up to 100 Hey
listen if I'm a burden on others hell
that's exactly it hell no I don't like
people knowing that I'm in the bathroom
doing my thing now I have to do it in
front people have to listen I don't want
to look like that that guy looks like a
white walker from freaking Game of
Thrones I'm good I'll say this I think
the saddest thing that anyone can
experience is like your children dying
before you or your grandkids and that's
something I get we're living in like
Fantasyland right here but for everyone
you know that you've ever known and
loved to die and then their kids all day
because you live in other words yeah
that could get aggressive if you really
want to know what it feels like go watch
the movie age of Adeline okay go watch
the movie by the way speaking of movies
I saw the judge I was gonna send you a
photo tell me let me explain some to you
I hated you for it because whatever song
they picked for that goddamn movie I was
like I was making food I'll just like
Bon Iver I was CR it was such dude
the judge was a great movie it was a
great movie you you think I'm joking is
I'm gonna be watching it on the plane
ride this weekend I've scheduled it with
where you go like where are you guys
going uh skiing okay very emotional very
very emotional citizens okay all right
sounds good so by the way Rob make a
note zero podcast for Adam wow that's
right Adam so tomorrow James O'Keefe
you're not on you're going to be on
tomorrow perfect you gotta you gotta
give me time I gave you two weeks of
crying
so tomorrow it's gonna be us what
happens if I don't watch the movie for a
month no problem dude we get a break
from you
we don't have a problem that's a
decision you gotta we should talk about
this story let's go to the Tipping story
we're gonna go to the top earning men
are cutting back on their work and we
want you to spend more time by yourself
and enjoy your become spend time without
intrapersonal okay all right so let's go
to the story when should you leave a tip
American sound off on cultural pressure
oh wow such terrible pressure people are
having right now if you enjoy eating
gout
then he could be feeling uh growing
cultural pressures around one of the
service Industries most controversial
topics tipping tipping at Quick Service
and to go establishments is frustrating
creates a social pressure saying nursing
students and CNA Addison read day trader
Sean McDonald and Reed Express
frustration at the expectation to tip
for drive through or to go services and
say they run into the issues frequently
Reid says she tips 15 on average for
quick Food Services and feels obligated
to tip when the worker is standing there
watching her McDonald's says he would
tip for good quality service but Express
concern about whether the gratuity goes
to the server the store owner or
corporate McDonald's suggested
businesses include fine print on their
tipping prompt specifying where the tip
goes so Adam go to you first thoughts on
tips and nothing's more Awkward than
just ordering some food it's you know
you go to Chicken Kitchen across the
street it's 11 12 bucks for your meal
then they hit you with how much do you
want to leave as a tip two three four
five it's like
okay now I'm face to face with the lady
she's like looking at you like so what's
she gonna do yeah but you're not gonna
give me three extra dollars for giving
you your foot it's like now it's awkward
I'm gonna I'm gonna assume I'm gonna
guess that she's Latina yeah with that
voice I just did right there but and I I
hate that by the way I hate awkward
moments they should have like like you
know I'm voting you go on that little
thing give me like a tip room why go in
there don't just stand there and make it
weird yeah with it yeah how much you're
gonna tell me how much I'm like I just
handed you your food yeah can you turn
around please like this is awkward yeah
I mean like after you're using this if
they're using the system by square or
toast they just turn the iPad around you
yeah and then they Point uh yeah just
right there yeah and they're staring at
you so um I'm not gonna name the name of
it but we take the girls and we love to
go out to
um it's a very creative dessert place
that uh makes you know frozen yogurt and
they use nitrogen it's real fun
and I asked one time I said hey if I tip
here where does this go and the girl
there says oh I don't know oh great and
so obviously it doesn't go to me because
otherwise she would cheerfully say oh it
goes to us we split it whoever's on
shift we split it
um like if you ever had uh you ask a
valet do I tip you I'll just put it on
the thing we split it yeah yeah you know
uh and so I'm I'm not on the tip thing
on the the retail cash register if I'm
just buying something you're handing it
to me we didn't have tips for many many
years and I'm not convinced that the the
core workers are getting it if I know
the workers getting it and they've done
something nice I will take care of that
person I agree I agree 100 I'm not I'm
I'm with them and I mind you I I tip
really really well and I don't even have
money like that because I know I'm being
like I tip to her sometimes they walk
away and they go are you and I'm being
dead serious like I went to go eat with
Kelly I tipped them I even asked I go
how much could I feel bad if I go under
but the the fact that the girl just
stays there I I'm at the point in my
life I'm 44 I go excuse me can you just
at least look over there it's just
awkward because I'm putting it and then
you're sitting there looking at it it
makes me feel it makes me feel you give
the old look over there you reach in and
you grab the tip out exactly I go fire
and I just
Bernie Mac told a joke about her looking
at him do you know this is a dirty joke
it's a [__] awesome joke here it
comes I can't say oh yeah
Bernie Mac is my guy but yeah God bless
his soul yeah two-year-old she the
shepherd for the devil you know whatever
she says the other two [__]
you tell the story about your uncle that
doesn't even speak English and him
downstairs what do you mean him down
yeah you should walk two four
six-year-old Bernie was good what's his
what's his joke
she's hurting everybody
what's the joke with the tip he'll tell
us after Bernie Mac 30. oh okay so
anyways so uh uh tipping
um yeah if the money doesn't go to them
I don't uh over tip if the money is like
a pool like if they do a pool tip I
don't like that like you know sometimes
valet they'll do a pool tip I'm like
yeah can I give it to you no it's gonna
go to pool okay so here's 20 bucks I was
gonna give you 100 bucks but here's 20
bucks Hey where's this going to go this
is going to go to me fantastic so here's
a tip that goes to you now
if service is bad will you tip zero say
you go to a restaurant it is absolutely
horrible Tom insult late annoying
nothing they do is Right absolutely
horrible will you tip zero yes I will if
it is a hundred percent on the server
but if the kitchen was slow there's
other things there and they've got like
seven tables and they're running around
they didn't have enough people there
very good for you then I cut some slack
but if I know it's just that person
their attitude forgotten the order
putting the wrong order you know just or
you know the the the one I hate is the
appetizers comes out in 13 seconds later
somebody else comes out of the kitchen
with the dinner and I'm like I didn't
ask you just to appetizer doesn't give
us a little time yeah and that's all on
the screen are you ready for this Pat so
me and Kelly yesterday went to go eat
ramen now when it's really good spot
right normally when you walk in there's
one one of the waitresses hi she's
welcoming times it's an experience she's
awesome right this girl I could already
tell from the beginning we sat there I
mean Kelly are chilling and then Pat
nothing is I had to I had to walk to a
table get the menu I brought the menu
we'll look it through it I order an
appetizer we order the meal uh I I got
Arnold Palmer are we like it's we like
it the same way I go little iced tea
that she shows up it's all lemonade she
goes I trust me I put iced tea she
didn't I asked for iced tea on the side
should our ramen comes no appetizer I
don't say anything and then all this it
was just the worst she was young or
whatever I still I even asked I'll tell
you Kelly how much and we even put even
more than unless they do something
personal to me like hey but and I told
her no we don't want it I still feel bad
unless they're an [__] or all I'm
saying to you is DM Vinnie to come to
your restaurant because whether you give
shitty service or not he's gonna tip I
feel bad for the person because you're
such a socialist at restaurant I'll add
one more thing
Tom when you when you give the zero tip
do you give any insight or any
encouragement to the server meaning like
I've been a server before and I I think
server is actually a great job if you
want to do anything in sales you're out
there you're working you have a system
you gotta you know meet with people you
know you're upselling it's such a great
job to kind of to understand people and
social dynamics but if there's someone
who's a shitty server the last thing
I'll do is just tip them nothing and be
like and because that's gonna these
[__] people they don't it's like I'll
say Hey listen I'm a 20 guy across the
board decent service great service 20
unless unless there's something extra I
would say Hey listen I'm a 20 tip guy
sorry to let you know you did not
deserve meet the standard but I'm gonna
tip you so and I don't want you to feel
like things are you know that you didn't
do your job but the next time I come
here the next customer just understand
that they're probably not going to tip
you like this because your service was
pretty poor here's some money it's eight
bucks whatever it is but you know keep
improving I actually like that a lot
more I just hate those awkward moments
you guys are very Noble I may write
something I may write like something
simple that says like I don't know
what's going on what's up I know I'll
say that I don't know what's up but the
service was non-existent oh you're gonna
write the note I love it you have a pen
on you or do you ask them for a pen or
no I'll use no if they've given me
enough because nothing's more Awkward
hey can I buy it
yeah no no no I mean you ain't [__] no
they bring your credit card back with
the with the slip yeah by the way I'm
not mean I don't just say it's
unfortunate your mom was pro-life you
know what
you know
you know it's like
I'm taking a stand
well she just don't you see her head
come up like who the hell was that by
the way if you want to hear real stories
would restaurants Mario moral tigrin
will tell you plenty of stories of what
happens with restaurants I've walked in
Hostess was bad I'll walk at him he's
beautiful uh waitress is bad you know or
wait waiter is bad you know we'll have
the conversation but the best thing to
do is to follow it here's what you don't
here's what we don't do enough of if the
waiter or the waitress is great
I always do this I love doing this I'll
say
um can I talk to your manager please and
they'll always say oh God is everything
fine and I'll say it in a very serious
tone it's fine but I need to speak with
your manager immediately and then they
walk away and they're like oh like what
happened we and they'll say is there
anything I can do I'm telling you I need
to speak with the manager is it the food
is there anything I can do certain the
manageable show up and you see them
watching from a distance on what we're
saying to the manager to say what's your
name Johnny Johnny how long you been the
manager here three years I gotta tell
you Johnny I don't know what you do here
I have no idea what you do with your
guys
but our waitress was absolutely amazing
she was phenomenal kind respectful on
time the iced tea lemonade Arnold Palmer
90 10 Flawless she brought the balsamic
glaze she brought the honey uh uh asking
if we'd like more three refills she
wasn't just bringing one riffle and
walking away not coming back up she's a
perfect so whatever service you guys got
fantastic please make sure she knows
about it I want to make sure you knew
about it she's amazing you guys are
lucky to have her that's amazing and
then they come back the waitress yeah
and by the way ever like eight out of
ten times when you say this they bring
you free dessert 100 and it's like you
know that happens we got this don't
worry about this we got that but you
know I think if you're gonna give the
negative feedback you also have to give
the positive feedback if they crush it I
agree they crush it give them the one I
agree phenomenal the place the casa de
Angela I don't know if you ever heard I
know have you heard of that I've never
been to before but it's a nice place
it's like House of Angela really yeah
yeah they actually have a balsamic uh
glaze that's on the top here it's
actually weird because I think it's a
picture of you on it but Pat like those
servers those servers are the epitome of
what you just said every single time
I've gone there with you and your family
or or Tom we've been there all of us
yeah they are on it the iced tea
Michelle
is unfreakable if Michaela's the kind of
guy if I ever was in a restaurant
business I would want to kill at my
restaurant and I would pay him twice the
salaries getting paid right now which
ones that was a tall Italian guy who's
just when he talks about how much he
misses Italy his family he talks about
his wife he talks about he's just the
kind of guy that you want to be taken
care of by like a guy like that got you
phenomenal yes we went to the uh
Angelo's on Monday or whatever it was a
couple days ago right somebody sitting
at our table
Adam's confused so we go sit in the
table all the way to back
so then Adam comes in then this guy says
but let me tell you what mistakes just
we just made out right so what happened
he says those guys are sitting there
because they said they're here to see
somebody and they own the club 11 and we
figured they're here to stay with you
guys so you always have people that come
in I want to see you so we put them at
your table we thought he's your friend
he says what do you want us to do I said
well you can't ask him to leave anyway
so Adam goes do you guys know those guys
are the owners of 11 there's I know them
from like I'm like anyways long story
yeah but you know what happened Nutella
Pizza you get ice cream you get this you
get espresso you get that Adam and Tom
are talking about how he was you know
apologizing on my behalf and they're
just having this great conversation
together just a fantastic well I will
say is by the way it was so awkward
because I walked in and you knew the
guys it's at Pat's table he's always
said that we sit yeah I go I I know
these what are the odds I know these
yeah weird they run 11 in Miami shout
out to you guys
um so I go and say hey it was just
awkward but Pat is what I know about Pat
is Pat is a be back
I'll be back at here Pat whether it was
in whether it was in Dallas you hit two
restaurant it was Yard House with our
friend Jason or Toulouse was what was
her her name
it's like that's like Pat's there two
restaurants he's a be back in in Boca
when we were there we were either at uh
the not the yard house or the other
house
something um Harry Rex Farmhouse yeah
Farmhouse Marine there we were at uh
Louis uh Louis bossy and then here
obviously Angelo's and or the other
Angelos well now we have to change
apparently yeah apparently but you're
the type of guy that wants something's
good and it works and they treat you
right you'll be back so you know you
know these guys are working out the uh
the club that we're building that when
people come to the first live podcast
that we do we're building a cigar lounge
in the back and by the way the three
tickets that we have the one that
they're gonna go to the Cigar Lounge to
Premiere those two sold out already
there's nothing left if there's only the
general tickets left to send them back
so when we announce do I have to buy it
now but wait let me just tell you the
story so the guys that are doing our uh
uh real estate stuff or they're doing
our construction stuff they've done a
bunch of things here they've done a
bunch of things at different buildings
I'm talking to them I said listen guys
if you're good to us I don't change
relationship I stick with partners that
we do business with
24 7 they're working at the office to
build a cigar lounge in the back the
club 24 7. they're working at the club
The Cigar Lounge is looking insane the
humidor what we're gonna do the
structure of the Cigar Lounge is going
to be fantastic anyways
um what's crazy is that it's three weeks
away yeah we're getting banana we're
getting to the end and we're gonna we're
gonna watch the Super Bowl there as well
and have a diamond all this other stuff
but let me do let's do one or two more
stories and then we'll wrap it up and
I'll give the link and uh we uh shall go
from there What story do you guys want
to go into that we haven't gone into yet
yeah let's go to Alec Baldwin so here's
what happens with Alec Baldwin Alec
Baldwin accused of extremely Reckless
acts and rust killing Alec Baldwin and
the former uh armor on the film Russ has
been charged with involuntary
manslaughter in the fatal shooting of
the film cinematographer according to
court papers filed in the First Judicial
District Court in New Mexico prosecutors
accused Baldwin of not uh receiving
sufficient firearm training failing to
handle safety uh complaints putting his
finger on the trigger of a real firearm
instead of a replica and pointing the
firearm at the cinematographer and
director armorer Hannah Gutierrez Reid
was accused of not checking the rounds
she located loaded the Firearms into
allowing the rounds of the uh on the set
allowing ammunition to not be secured
failing to stay with the firearm and not
being qualified for the armor position
Baldwin has long maintained he is not
responsible for the fatal shooting
prosecutors told Baldwin was culpable
for not checking he was also culpable
for not checking the gun or ensuring
someone else did and for not attending
firearm safety training at uh Vinnie so
and and but mind you I was always a fan
of Alec Baldwin from Hunter Red October
and just all the movies and everything
but this guy showed his true colors um
even before Trump but then during like
all the incidents that he got into in
front of his house in Manhattan with all
the you know yelling out we don't try to
yell and get confrontational women to
all that stuff this is just a a a a
prime case of just the narcissist and
the hypocrite this guy went after the
NRA talking all this crap about guns and
nobody you know all these people that
are having guns bro the number one rule
with guns is what you guys know right
always treat it as if it's loaded one
100 he would have known this if he went
to the training because by the way uh he
didn't show up okay to the actual
required firearm training which you know
Mr Mr hypocrite guy when he showed up he
was distracted talking on the cell phone
prosecutor saying there's a photo of him
finger on the trigger acting like you
know like like a [__] like like trying
to point at people and stuff and like I
said if he knew if he went to the
training that's the problem with all
these people that are anti-gun and stuff
that hate gun some if you're trained on
it less accidents like this happen God
forbid and God Rest The Souls of the
people that passed away but it's always
the pot calling the kettle black all the
all the ones that bark and look at this
look at that like you're the ones that
are actually the idiots you know I mean
like he's he's the more and if he paid
attention and actually did the training
which I think the majority of Americans
should have some basic training because
God forbid you have to have a gun in
your hand none of this type of [__]
would happen
uh this has been going on for a long
time and so the prosecutors at a time to
talk to everybody and some of this
language that I see from the prosecutor
we're in the insurance industry
um there were three of us here Adam you
are pat you are does some of this
language look kind of like the thing
that uh an adjuster or lost control
would be saying because remember there's
insurance on that set that's going to
have to cover of course the loss that's
going to cover the loss of life there's
Insurance on there to cover lawsuits for
injuries on set it's there's huge you
know we have insurance when value
payment goes off and does a field shoot
we have insurance certificate not
attending firearm safety training you
know failing to handle safety complaints
and you know all of this to me sounds
like there's an investigation that's
done here and what happened on that set
was a terrible accident and tragedy and
it can be an accident and a tragedy but
it doesn't take away from the place that
doesn't look like that they did the
appropriate
um you know safety routine and if you've
ever gone
and had gun training and I have when
you're sitting standing there side by
side with someone who's teaching you
about maybe a pistol you're thinking of
buying and you go to a firing range they
always say down and Away down and away
so you point it down away and he says
when I hand it to you you look
and so he says and he goes and he'll say
that's loaded look and so I look and
that's always what they teach you so
that when you receive a firearm I mean
it's what they did in the military Pat
right don't assume what the guy just
told you is correct down and away and
look and I I think sorry dude Baldwin if
there's pictures of you fooling around
there and you didn't do the safety
training you're culpable it's a terrible
tragedy you can call it an accident
picture culpable dude when you say
culpable I guess we'll see what happens
here like I don't think anybody thinks
that he is going to be he's not he's not
gonna go to jail he didn't want to
murder this person let's get realized it
was not first second third degree murder
I don't know if manslaughter is going to
be the charge but I think we're losing
side this lady lost her life innocent
lady you know why is the gun even loaded
to begin with with real bullets what the
hell is that all about and then his
defense of like I didn't pull the
trigger it's like I don't know how that
works whatever that defense is but at
the end of the day this is a really sad
situation I think he's going to lose
some sort of civil lawsuit have to pay
the family a ton of money I don't see
Alec Baldwin Alex a list Hollywood actor
going to jail nothing at all no no no so
I think that's the bottom line no yeah
100 but it just goes It goes to show you
though got like any gun on could you
imagine as being in Hollywood being on a
set even when they would give you a gun
out of and I'm an ex-military cop always
away never and dude I'm pretty sure
every guy we all know this if you got a
fake gun that you think is not loaded
you're doing Quick Draw McGraw you're
acting like a cowboy and then boom and
then tragic but it could have been
avoided to your point Adam that's what I
call it it's a terrible tragedy a
tragedy that came out of an accident but
it was an avoidable accident and on set
you know the culpability goes to he's
not going to go to jail but there's
Insurance here and there's you know
settlements and there's things like that
kind of the ugly side of this and um it
does it doesn't bring back a A Gifted
filmmaker it's unfortunate look I I
don't I don't care if the the person is
sir uh agrees with me disagrees with me
we're on the same page we're not on the
same page you're on the team you're not
on the team nobody wants to see a story
like this because an innocent person was
killed on the set and this guy's life is
ruined I mean you know Alec messed up
his life for being arrogant foolish and
not being responsible for it it's just
something that it happens to everybody
but there isn't anything that's a higher
level than this you took someone's life
so uh uh you know how much of that
responsibility is on him how much are
the responsibility on the other guy why
the hell do you have a real weapon
loaded weapon on the set anyways like as
an actor I'm assuming the actor's
already thinking about doing their part
their role like what else you want me to
also so I don't know maybe the funding
they didn't have enough funding for they
were too cheap in that area that they
didn't want to make that investment who
knows but you're dealing with an
a-lister so you know anyways what are
you doing taking a movie I don't know
what Alec Baldwin is worth why are you
taking how much money were they paying
you to be on a set that's being cheap
about it there's so many questions I
have but it's not my job it's the it's
the juries and the judge's job to make
that decision did they finish the movie
Pat do you know if they actually
wouldn't even tell forward with them
first of all Imagine That movie oh my
God this is the movie would you want to
go watch the movie like that maybe you
know it's like one of those uh I don't
know dude that's pretty crazy yeah
filming uh resume yeah they they're okay
dude what a awkward because mind you bro
if there's guns in that scene there's
guns throughout the whole damn movie
it's like I was like I wouldn't I'd be
like nobody even touched this guy we're
gonna put like a fake gun in your hand
we don't want anybody pointing or doing
anything well let's listen this is a uh
uh again we'll see what happened here at
this point it's the chance like Adam
says your chance of somebody like him
and a list are going to jail like Kevin
Spacey you're seeing that stuff it's uh
probably not likely he'll have to pay
but we'll see what happens next but uh
uh rap I think it's time for us to show
the link to the website fight for those
that want to go to the event it is
called 59.90 live
59.90 live the premiere premium ticket
and VIP sold out within the first 10
minutes so those two are gone there's
only a few tickets left on the hundred
dollar tickets and if you can zoom in a
little bit that shows what comes with
that uh you get the general seating you
get the swag gift is what you get with
that one but it's a hundred dollars to
come in live and be with us it'll be the
first one we're giving away some a bunch
of things for people that are coming to
the first one it's gonna be a really
cool event uh live and some will see the
Cigar Lounge we can't wait to see uh
we'd love to see everybody but obviously
that's not possible right now but we are
looking forward to seeing many of you
there who are able to buy the tickets go
to
5990live.com if you want to put it in
chat as well as comments as well as
description uh it's
59.90 live uh uh let me just do so I
have to buy a general ticket is that
what you're saying well that's all
that's left even if you wanted to buy
anything else you couldn't but so Tom
can't escort me to like the cigar lounge
or check it out it can't be your export
after hours for different reasons
anyways
so so looking forward to seeing
everybody who is getting registered uh
uh there uh uh hang on one second uh
give me one second yeah okay so outside
of that I think there was one other last
announcement that we had to make about
did you have a show you got a show have
a show today at uh 4 P.M southcast 4 P.M
you gotta show sauce cast you got bizdoc
that's uh you guys are talking about
launching around March is exciting and
then I know you got some crazy stuff
valuable name and comedy please uh
subscribe guys because I have some fun
and we also have Adam's birthday
[Laughter]
there you go happy birthday to you
happy birthday dear Adams happy birthday
to you
the big 30. hi Adam 39.
39 somehow guys looking good it's
impressive that is awesome happy
birthday as your mom would say happy
birthday you never call you never know
me Adam thank you so how's it feel man
tell us what's the difference you know
what turning 40 again for the third time
feels great guys feels great you're
looking great you look fine you know I'm
excited for the the keyword that you
talked a lot of responsibility of that
second phase of your life
looking forward to uh that Clarity
responsibility and taking ownership for
the next phase of my life but we have a
guy you know we're debating whether
we're gonna live to 150. I've got a goal
of 100 we're at 42 about to be 43 right
now I I have a bet to win by 44 I hope
knock on wood we'll see but uh traveling
this weekend for Jackson Hole Wyoming
for the birthday sick
excited to decide to do this but thank
you pbd this is great I'll make sure to
chug the rest of this uh Brew it
champagne before the sauce cast but what
is this great thing and for all of you
out there all you young ladies that are
27 and a half years old you're now
eligible to maybe go to dinner and date
with Adam thank you and Tom by the way
it's 21 plus to enter 21. the the ride
but uh yeah thank you for this don't
discriminate Tom anyways man I think you
know the the consensus is out a lot of
people are saying the atom of two and a
half years ago on the podcast or two
years ago versus today he's changing you
know
anytime he's growing on me I don't
really know what that means maybe it's a
you know but but uh you know it's a lot
of uh a lot of good things are happening
the future looks very bright I keep that
on I keep that on my wrist right here
listen at work out improve out
strategize Outlast that that's what it
is I had fun this is awesome happy
birthday thank you he has joined
saucecast today all day his Show's going
to be this afternoon take everybody if
we do it tomorrow great you'll see us
you won't see Adam because he's got to
see the judge and he said he's not going
to watch until his flight so he won't be
on but we'll see we'll see we'll do it
tonight if we don't do it tomorrow we'll
do it again next week take care have a
great weekend bye-bye thank you guys
suggestion